the partygate inquiry is not about
whether there were parties in number 10
during covert lockdown we know there
were remember the birthday party the
suitcase of booze the broken swing and
this with the parents to condone uh
what's the answer I don't know
well the Met police issued 126 fixed
penalty notices including one for Boris
Johnson and another to Rishi sunak civil
servant Sue gray investigated 15 events
some of which were drunken and Rowdy she
concluded that there were failures of
leadership and judgment by different
parts of number 10 and the cabinet
office all of this quickened the
conclusion of Boris Johnson's
Premiership and the inquiry which is all
about him is fraught with political
danger it could possibly lead to a
by-election and the former PM losing his
Uxbridge seat now we're a long long way
from that but let me explain how we
could get there now seven MPS make up
the team at asked by Parliament with
investigating conservatives you can see
the four here with blue around their
pictures have a majority but these
parliamentarians are all pretty
independent minded their chair is the
veteran labor MP at Harriet Hartman they
will focus on what Boris Johnson said in
the Commons if he misled MPS and whether
that constitutes a contempt of
parliament they're looking at just 68
words at two prime ministers questions
firstly this on the 1st of December 2021
all guidance was followed completely
during number 10. all guidance was
followed completely well a week later
that line had changed I have been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged that there was no
party and that and that no covid rules
were broken I'm sickened myself and
Furious about that
to him
[Music]
the the rules
the guidance was followed and the rules
were followed at all times
so why did Boris Johnson's answers
change and who was he being repeatedly
assured by we understand the committee
has requested the PM's official briefing
documents and is taking written evidence
from witnesses to help answer their key
question what did Boris Johnson know and
when they will have a chance to ask him
face to face when he's called to give
evidence if they decide he misled
Parliament and if they decide that
constitutes a contempt they must then
choose a sanction that could include a
suspension from The Commons now MPS
would need to approve this but if Boris
Johnson was suspended for at least 10
sitting days that would trigger a recall
petition and then if just 10 percent of
Voters if Boris Johnson's Uxbridge and
South ruislip constituency signed a
petition he would lose his job as an MP
but he'd be eligible to stand in the
by-election that would follow now this
inquiry has been going on in private for
months it's gradually reaching its
Climax and depending what's discovered
it could end very badly for Boris
Johnson